Well this morning we're continuing on in our Firm Foundations series.
So if you've got a Bible please turn with me to Acts chapter 2.
Acts chapter 2.
This morning we're looking at the doctrine of the Holy Spirit.
So in this series we're walking through our statement of faith and we're looking
at what we believe and why it matters.
And we've come to the statement on the Holy Spirit which is on the back of your
worship guides if you want to look there.
It's important that we read through this together here at the start of the church so
we're all on the same page.
So as we believe in the deity and personhood of the Holy Spirit
who convicts the world concerning sin, righteousness and judgment,
he is sent to indwell the believer, provide power for righteous living,
equip people for service in the church and guide them to truth.
He is the deposit guaranteeing our inheritance to come.
So the main scripture we're going to be looking at to see about the doctrine of
the Holy Spirit is Acts chapter 2.
It doesn't cover everything we could say about the Holy Spirit this morning but
it's a great passage to get us started looking in that direction.
So we'll be looking at the Holy Spirit this week and the doctrine of the church
next week and so both of these are present here in this chapter.
I'll begin reading in verse 1.
Now there were dwelling in Jerusalem Jews devout men from every nation under heaven.
And at this sound the multitude came together and they were bewildered because
each one was hearing them speak in his own language.
And they were amazed and astonished saying,
are not all these who are speaking Galileans?
And how is it that we hear each one of us in his own native language?
Parthians and Medes and Elamites residents of Mesopotamia, Judea and Cappadocia,
Pontus and Asia, Phrygia and Pamphylia, Egypt and the parts of Libya belonging to Cyrene.
Visitors from Rome both Jews and Prostylites, Cretans and Arabians.
We hear them telling in our own tongues the mighty works of God.
And all were amazed and perplexed saying to one another,
what does this mean?
But others mocking said, they are filled with new wine.
But Peter standing with the eleven lifted up his voice and addressed them,
men of Judea and all who dwell in Jerusalem,
let this be known to you and give ear to my words.
For these people are not drunk as you suppose since it's only the third hour of the day.
But this is what was uttered through the prophet Joel.
And in the last days it shall be, God declares,
that I will pour out my spirit on all flesh,
and your sons and your daughters shall prophesy,
and your young men shall see visions,
and your old men shall dream dreams,
even on my male servants and female servants.
In those days I will pour out my spirit and they shall prophesy.
And I will show wonders in the heavens above and signs on the earth below,
blood and fire and vapor of smoke,
and the sun shall be turned to darkness,
and the moon to blood,
before the day of the Lord comes,
the great and magnificent day,
and it shall come to pass that everyone who calls upon the name of the Lord
shall be saved.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much for giving us your word.
Father, I pray that your spirit would open our eyes to see more of Jesus there.
I pray this in His name. Amen.
I wonder how early you get ready for Christmas,
if you're one of those people who, you know,
have already started, you've already got the Christmas tree,
I've already got the lights out,
or whether or not you're like me,
and it's not until after Thanksgiving,
you know, the day after Thanksgiving or something,
that's when you get it going.
Last week, I don't know if anybody else saw this here,
but there was a video going viral,
which was about the Griswolds of Gardendale.
Now, I'm taking a risk saying this,
because you may very well know the Griswolds of Gardendale.
So there's a local family who've made them use,
because they have gotten started with Christmas early,
and their house is absolutely decked with lights,
and it's beautiful,
and they had this big ceremony kind of outside their house,
where they got together with family and neighbors,
and they had the power ready to go,
and as soon as the power hits,
they bust out with joy to the world,
and they said, they said,
Joy to the world, the Lord has come,
let earth receive her kings.
This is kind of a beautiful, hilarious, wonderful moment.
Well, in our text this morning,
the holidays have arrived,
but it's a specific feast.
It's the Feast of Pentecost.
This is a Jewish harvest festival,
and this particular harvest,
this particular Pentecost is like no other
on this day, the people of God
are empowered
by the Spirit of God
that they might be a light
to the nations.
This is the day when it happens,
on the day of Pentecost.
This is a good place for us to see
who the Spirit of God is,
because this is the day
when God pours out
His Spirit upon His church.
Now, like I said earlier,
this text does not address
any question we might have
about the Spirit, although I'd be happy
to speak with anybody about
any one of those questions.
But this is really a crucial passage
when it comes to understanding the person
and work of the Holy Spirit.
So who is the Holy Spirit?
We're going to look at this by just looking at
two simple things, following the pattern
that we see really in Acts chapter 1
and then in Acts chapter 2.
So first of all we're going to see the promise of the Spirit,
and then we're going to see the empowering presence
of the Spirit, so those two things.
First of all, let's look and think together
about the promise of the Spirit.
The arrival of the Spirit
here in Acts chapter 2 was
in fulfillment of a promise made by God.
Twice
in Acts chapter 1 and 2
it's referred to as the promise of the Father.
So the Father has made this promise
to send the Spirit.
This promise from the Father
comes from two major sources
that we read about in
chapters 1 and 2. First of all
it comes through the source of Jesus himself.
So in chapter 1
verses 1 to 8 we see
that Jesus meets with his apostles
and so God has given this promise
to his son who's then communicating this
to the apostles who are recording it
for us that the Spirit is coming.
And then when you get to chapter 2
verses 16 to 21
you see that this promise of the Spirit
is a promise that had been made in the Old Testament
repeatedly. And there's a particular Old Testament promise
that is referenced.
Interestingly these
sources about the coming of the Spirit
are inspired by the Spirit
as they give these promises.
And I'm not just
taking that by inference, it actually says that.
So you look at that start of chapter 1
Jesus is telling
his apostles these things
through the Holy Spirit.
So it is by the Spirit that he is teaching the apostles.
And then later on
in chapter 1 you get Peter
who is teaching. And he is not teaching about the Spirit
but very interestingly
he quotes a Psalm in chapter 1
and he talks about how this Psalm
was given to David by the Holy Spirit.
So it is the Spirit who is speaking
and David who is communicating this
Psalm. Alright so the Spirit
is giving the word both you have through the mouth
of Jesus, the mouth of David and all the other
prophets in the Old Testament.
So the Spirit inspired the Scriptures
including those that speak
about his own arrival.
But let's slow down and let's look at this promise
specifically, the promise of the Spirit
as it comes to us.
Alright so let's look at it in terms of
being a promise of Jesus.
So this promise of the Father to send the Spirit
is communicated by the Son.
And Acts chapter 1 isn't the first place
that this happened.
By the way we're going to reference a few places in Acts chapter 1
so if you want to look it up that's not going to be on your
worship guide, sorry I couldn't fit everything
in there.
But also you can look back at John chapter 14
all the way to chapter 16.
That's a key passage speaking about
the Holy Spirit.
It speaks about the Spirit as the Helper.
It talks about him proceeding
from the Father.
Alright so this is a reference to
his deity and his
personhood we might say. The deity and personhood
of the Spirit.
Alright so he's proceeding from the Father
so the Spirit is God.
But also when it speaks about the Spirit
it doesn't talk about it.
It speaks about he.
He is coming into the world.
So the Spirit is not
an energy or a feeling
or a force. The Spirit
is a person. He's a person
within the Triune God
who is Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
But there as well
in John 14 to 16 Jesus promises
that when he goes
when he returns to his Father
he will send the Spirit.
And that's the promise that's now repeated
when we get to the Book of Acts.
See after Jesus rose again from the dead
we read that he spent 40 days with the
apostles. He was teaching them
about the Kingdom of God.
He's witnessed by many people
but he gives particular focus to
these early leaders that he had chosen
to lead the church.
And one of the main things that he instructs
these leaders to do is
to stay in Jerusalem
to remain in Jerusalem and wait
for the promise of the Spirit.
So he tells them what would happen once the
fullness of the Spirit comes upon them
in Acts chapter 1 and verse 8
because you will receive power
when the Holy Spirit has come upon you
and you will be my witnesses in Jerusalem
in all Judea and Samaria
and to the ends of
the earth.
We'll see this in a moment but the Spirit
is going to empower them to bear witness
to Christ both locally
and globally.
His arrival is going to
enable them to live as
citizens in Christ's Kingdom
and to proclaim him to the ends of the earth
as his representatives.
Now when you get to chapter 2
that promise is what
is being fulfilled.
As it's fulfilled you see
it in reference to
these pictures and promises
in the Old Testament. Jesus
makes this promise to his apostles
now the promises of the Old Testament
but let's look at what actually
happened, the kind of narrative that we're given here.
Alright so the church is gathered together
in one place
and in that place they have been devoting themselves
to prayer.
And as they are there this
mighty rushing winds
comes from heaven. They're hearing the sound of this.
It fills the house that they are in
and we read about how tongues of
fire or something that appears
as tongues of fire rests upon
each of them that is gathered there
and they're all filled with the Spirit.
So you got some kind of unusual things
happening here. Not something you see
every day or experience every day.
So why does it play out in this way?
Why do we have these unusual details
here?
Well something very similar happens
in the Old Testament and repeatedly so
in the Old Testament when God's presence
dwells among his
people. There were particular
places where this happened.
So Exodus chapter 40 for example
the Tabernacle has been
constructed.
It's now finished and God's
glorious presence fills the Tabernacle.
And his presence
appears there in a cloud by day
but also a fire
by night.
And there God's presence goes with
his people.
So God's presence is dwelling in that place
and fire appearing as well.
Think of a place like Second Chronicles
chapter 7.
And you see that the construction of the temple
is now complete. Just as God
dwelt among his people in the Tabernacle
now he dwells among his people through the
temple. King Solomon
builds this house
to bear witness to God's
name. And when the construction
of that temple is completed
Solomon then prays and God's
glorious presence fills
the temple. And as that
happens fire comes down from
heaven and consumes the sacrifices
that have been laid out there.
This is the place where heaven and earth
meet. God is dwelling
among his people.
The question then needs to be asked
well where does God's presence
on earth dwell now?
Where is God making his presence in glory
known? And Acts chapter 2
answers. In his people
it's not a place but a
people that is where God's presence dwells
because a king
who is greater than Solomon
Jesus
constructed this house
for God's spirit to dwell
in. What is this house that has been
constructed?
Well it's his people
it's God's spirit
filling his people
the church. He builds this temple
with living stones.
You know buildings can be useful
tools for ministry but
God's presence, God's
spirit
dwells in his people
wherever they are, wherever they
means God is present with them
more about that later on.
Well after this happens
they begin to speak in other
tongues and it makes it clear here
because it talks about all these people
gathering from other places and they're
hearing these tongues, they're hearing
their own languages so that's what's being spoken
about here. So other languages are being
spoke as the spirit is
giving utterance to these people who've
now been filled with the spirit as the church
is the spirit. So during the festival
of Pentecost you have all these
observant Jews from all around the
world in places where these different
languages are spoken traveling to Jerusalem
and all of a sudden they're hearing
these different things spoken
it's specific to say the mighty works of
God. So hearing things about God
and his mighty works spoken
but they're being spoken by
Galileans specifically
it says. Now these are the Galileans
are kind of more country people
they were known for their accent that sort
of thing. They weren't the sort of people you'd
expect all of a sudden to be speaking in all
of these different languages. It was clear
that this was a miracle
imagine what it would
be like to all of a sudden hear somebody
if you're from somewhere else speaking in your
own language. It's amazing. Now all of this
was happening at once. And this was
amusing to some and some of them joke
about how these people must
be intoxicated.
But Peter lifts up his voice and he explains
that what they're witnessing
is a promise being fulfilled
it was the promise of God
in Joel chapter 2 and other places
to pour out his
spirits. God promised to pour out
his spirit upon all flesh
of young and old
sons and daughters.
Here's the significance of that
in the Old Testament the spirit of God
is present and he's at
work but he's poured out
upon specific people
for specific tasks.
Right? So God's
spirit is poured out on another prophet
to speak his word
but now God's spirit is poured out
upon all of his people
and so you have all of them declaring
the mighty works of God
speaking about him to others.
If Julie and I are ever in need of a good
crime we pull up on
YouTube videos of soldiers
returning I don't know if you've ever
seen those you know it's such
a moving thing to watch
somebody's unexpected and they return
home and there's the hugs and it always gets us.
But you know what
that's like if you've been separated from a loved one
for a long period of time for whatever
reason you know that that
could be a painful thing to go through. You know somebody living in
another part of the state to another part of the world
a missionary or whatever
and you kind of long to be together
and you might have that person
say writing to you
or you know phone calls or FaceTime
that sort of thing but it's not the same
as being together in the same room
and there's a particular
moment when they walk through
the door and you're finally
with one another.
This is what we see happening here
in Acts chapter 2. God has promised
all the way I'm going to
come I'm going to spin
my spirit I'm going to be present with
each one of you.
You know for years it was good to know
God's presence dwelling in the Tabernacle
or the temple it was wonderful to
hear people who were filled with his
spirit speaking his word but now
God is present and dwelling in
the life of every
believer.
So God keeps his promises
and he dwells
in the life of everyone who belongs
to him so if you put your
faith in Christ and you
belong to him God's spirit
dwells within you
and his spirit
is the deposit
which is a guarantee of an even
greater day that is yet to come
when we will be with God forever
in the new creation.
So although
we no longer wait for the promise
of the spirit as they were on this
occasion in Pentecost
we live
according to the promise of the spirit
we know God's presence
dwelling among us
so it does us well to pause
and to think about that as the
gathered people of God right now
God himself is
present with us
I pray that
by his spirit he would
enable us to know and
experience that reality by faith
as we lay hold of that
truth and we would know his
help. Well what is
the spirit going to help us to do
as we are filled with the spirit
following his lead? Well that's what I
want to see secondly is the
empowering presence of the spirit
God promises I'm going to come and be
with you by my spirit
I promise it's been fulfilled and now
the spirit is at work in powerful ways
but in what way is the spirit
powerfully at work? Well
there's three ways I want to draw your
attention to. One is
powerful work of regeneration
by that I mean
the Holy Spirit
gives new life
just as God breathed
life into Adam and he became a living
soul so the spirit of
God gives life to people who were
once dead in their
sins so we're dead spiritually
and we're giving new life when we
put our faith in Jesus but how
does that happen? The spirit of
God gives us life
and our faith in Jesus is the
evidence that God
has moved in. He's
at work he's giving us
this new life or he has given us this new life
you see the kind of
process of that in places like John
1618 which speaks about
the spirit convicting the world of sin
so it's the spirit who convicts us of sin
and the spirit is the one who opens
our eyes that we might see
Jesus for who he is we see that in
2nd Corinthians chapter 3 and
4 we recently saw
in John 3 that is the spirit
who gives life you see
in 1 John chapter 5 and verse 1
everyone who believes
that Jesus is the Christ has been
born of God that's the work
of the spirit so we're believing
because we've been born of God
this is exactly what we see
happen in practice in Acts chapter
2 although that's not
referenced specifically in that way we see
this happening as we see what
the rest of scripture says about the spirit
when Christ is proclaiming
that this harvest festival of
Pentecost you see that specifically
in verses 22 down to the end
of verse 41
3000 people
are given new life by the
spirit so it was wonderful how this
harvest festival we have this harvest
of people 3000 people
now believing in
Christ because they've been given new life
by the spirit this is
true once again
I have every believer in Romans 8
it's a good place to go to learn about the spirit
there it says if you don't have the spirit
you do not belong to Christ
because the spirit of God is the one
who unites us to Jesus
so that we're united to him
in his life and death and resurrection
that's a work of the spirit
once again 2nd Corinthians 3
and 4 the ministry of the spirit
is described as opening blind eyes
to see the glory of God in the face
of Jesus if you see Jesus
for how glorious he is it's because
the spirit opens your eyes
and here you got this
pouring out of the spirit on the church
at Pentecost this is this unique event
and this event is
which we covered this a little bit already
but it's descriptive rather than
prescriptive right so we have this
event that's happened just like Jesus
died and he rose again
so the promise of the fathers fulfilled
in the sending of the spirit
and so we live in light of that
as we live in the light of the fact
that God has sent his spirit
so we don't have a passive relationship
with the spirit it's not what that happened at Pentecost
I believed in Christ and now
my relationship with the spirit is kind of over
it's just something that left behind
this is that doctrinal proposition
because the power of the spirit is not just seen
in regeneration it's also seen
secondly in transformation
alright so the spirit of God
is dwelling in our lives now
he gives us this new life and now he's present
within us he's present for a reason
and that reason is to transform
us into the lightness
of Jesus
so you see some
powerful transformative
things happening in Acts 2
you got these Galileans
now speaking in these languages they've never
heard transformation
there's another kind of transformation
here too if you look at
John chapter 20 which you get a Bible of
it's just a couple pages over to your
left you see that
after Jesus and verse 19
after Jesus' death the disciples were
gathered together but they were gathered together
behind closed doors not just closed doors
but locked doors
so there's communication
of fear there as
they're gathered together like so Jesus has just been
taken out wants to say that they are
not next so it's obvious
why they would be behind closed doors
but these disciples now
at Pentecost the disciples who were once
gathered in fear are now out on
the streets of Jerusalem the very place
where Jesus had just been crucified
now they're out boldly proclaiming
the truth so it's gone from fear to
boldness how could that have
happened what made the difference
at least two things have happened one
is that they now know that Jesus
really did rise from the dead
and the risen Christ has met with them
and so this is evidence of the
resurrection as they go out and proclaim Jesus
but also
the thing that made the difference is
God has poured out his spirit
so Acts 1a
when the spirit comes they'll be filled
with power so they're
empowered to do what to be his witnesses
right so the spirit is the one
who's changing their lives
this is one of many ways
the spirit of God transforms the
people of God
a couple things that he transforms us to do
one is he enables us to grow
in the likeness of Jesus
he brings about a harvest of
righteousness in our lives
Galatians 5 verses 22 and 23
speaks about the fruit of the
spirit so the spirit of God
produces this kind of fruit in our lives
love
joy
peace
patience
goodness
faithfulness
self control
some of these might
feel okay with like we're doing alright
the fruit of the spirit
he's producing all of these things in our lives
we might be naturally inclined
to one direction or another
or might struggle in one way or another
but the spirit of God
is transforming us so that all of those
things are reflected in our lives
the fruit of the spirit
and we rely on his presence
to empower us to live
in ways that are pleasing to
God
he gives us new desires
and also a new power
to fulfill those new desires
and that comes
not from relying on ourselves
but from relying on
him we can't change ourselves
we rely on God
throughout our lives
he changes us
alright so that's the fruit of the spirit
transformation but also he doesn't just
enable us to grow in Christ's likeness
he also gives us gifts that we might
serve the body of Christ
so yes he produces these
graces we might call them in our lives
the things that should be true in the life of
every believer
and we can't say like sorry
I'm just not gifted in the area of patience
so you just have to bear with me
I'm an impatient person like he produces all of
that fruit in our lives it's what God
wants from us
but he also gives unique gifts
to us individually as believers
unique ways that we can serve the church
and encourage one another
and I've been so
encouraged as we've gotten going
at Trinity Fellowship it's been wonderful
to see like gifts being released
because I've had people ask me like
are there any particular needs?
well if you see it there's probably a need
if you come up with an idea we probably need help in that area
but the wonderful news with that
God is
gifts that he has already
given
he's fanning those into flame
within the life of his people
you know the New Testament speaks about spiritual gifts
in a number of different places
we don't have time to read all of them
but you go to a place like a Romans 12
or 1 Corinthians
12 to 14 or 1 Peter
4 and you'll see that
there but let me just read a bit of
1 Corinthians 12 verses 4
to 7 because there's a picture
that is given
of what God is doing in terms
of pouring out spiritual gifts upon his people
says now there are
a variety of gifts
but the same spirit
and there are a variety
there's a variety of
service but the same Lord
and there are varieties of activities
but it is the same God
who empowers them all in everyone
to each is given
the manifestation of the spirit
for the common good
Paul then goes on to talk about the church
as a body, kind of an illustration there
and this body has different parts
but that body with different parts
has the same spirit
dwelling
and so God has given us
all complimentary
gifts for the common good
of the church
and the one who empowers us
all together and unites us in this
is that same spirit
and these unique distinctions
begin to emerge in the life of the church
as we just look for any opportunity
to serve one another by the power
of the spirit
and so maybe the follow up to this is not going to be
let me give you a link
to a spiritual gifts survey that you can go
and fill out online, I'm sure that those have
some really good uses and that sort of thing
but the call here
isn't like really focus on yourself
like naval gaze until you find that
specific niche thing that you
absolutely know that you're gifted in
and then serve in that way
and the call is to be transformed by the spirit
so we have a heart to serve
one another for the common good
and as we come with that posture
relying not on ourselves but on the spirit
gifts begin to emerge
and become evident to others
and as we see that emerging in the lives of one another
let's affirm that and encourage that
in each other
and there will be plenty of opportunities to serve
and I'm tempted to just
list them now but
come speak to me and especially Rebecca
afterwards
sorry
one more thing
spirit transforms us not just
through regeneration giving us life
and transformation making us more like Jesus
but also in the area
of proclamation
so although the spirit is
very evidently at work
in this narrative here when it comes to
Peter's sermon
after he quotes the prophet Joel
he only mentions
the Holy Spirit two times
right this major event
has just happened
the arrival of the spirit God himself
is now dwelling his people
but this arrival of the spirit
isn't marked by
a lot of attention being given to the spirit
rather it's marked by
a sermon that focuses
on the person and work
of Jesus
so the spirit of God
empowers Peter to
proclaim Christ
there's a specific thing about Jesus
that the arrival of his spirit
reveals in chapter 2 verse 33
you see that it reveals
that he truly has ascended to
his heavenly throne that Jesus
really is Lord of all
so Jesus has ascended to heaven
he said when I have ascended to my father
I will send the spirit so how can we know
that this invisible thing has happened
that he has truly ascended
to his heavenly throne
by the work of the spirit here on earth
this is what Peter is
saying here
so the arrival of the spirit
underscores and empowers the message
of Pentecost and that message
is centered upon Jesus
his crucifixion, his resurrection
and his lordship as the one
who now reigns over
all things
this lines up exactly with what Jesus said
in John chapter 15 in verse 26
he said when the helper comes
whom I will send to you from the father
the spirit of truth who proceeds from the father
he will bear
witness about me
this is the work of the spirit
to call our attention
not to himself but to Jesus
there can be a temptation sometimes
to have an unhealthy
focus on the miraculous
manifestations
of the spirit
now please don't misunderstand me
I absolutely believe in miracles
that they can and do
happen, God can do whatever he wants
whenever he wants
but signs exist
these kind of miraculous signs
not to draw attention to themselves
any more than a road
sign is there to draw attention to itself
the road sign is there to point you
to something else
miraculous signs of the spirit
are there to point us
to Jesus
to obsess over the miraculous
is to miss the point
the spirit is powerfully at work
in the lives of all of his people
wise so that we might see
and know more of Jesus
and in seeing and knowing more of him
be changed into his likeness
and in being changed into his likeness
bear witness to him
in the world
that we live in
so imagine you're at the
final game of the world series
it's just happened
it's gone into the
107th inning or however long
it lasted for those of you who kept up with it
it was late, early hours in the morning
you're there, you're watching
and your eyes are on the field
and as you're looking at it
it seems like the game is about to be finished
you look at the person next to you
and they're turned
and they're looking in the opposite direction
they are just focused on the
lights of the stadium
they are absolutely impressed with these lights
and you think well this person has lost their mind
here we are at the world series
and they're focused on the lights
now are the lights important for that world series game
absolutely
they have a role in that game
like you need to see what's happening on the field
you can see what's happening as well
but those lights are there and you can look at them
you should know how they work and all the rest
but they are there for the purpose of
shining a spotlight
putting the headlights on
what's happening there on the field
in the same way with the spirit
the person and work of the spirit is crucial
it is important we need to understand
that the spirit is there to put the floodlights
upon whom Jesus
is to show us
him, shine a spotlight
so when he empowers his church
he does so that we might know Jesus
and make him known
and when we proclaim
Christ we do so
in fulfillment of the promise of the spirit
so let's think about this
God himself
let's return to this again
is present with us now
in the person of his spirit
think of it
when we come here together
we don't just come to be with one another
and we don't just come to think thoughts
about God
to say things about God
although that's part of it
when we come together we come to
meet with God himself
and in the New Testament that is called
the fellowship of the Holy Spirit
the Lord is here
so what is the spirit doing in our midst
he's showing us Christ
changing us into his lightness
that his glory might shine brightly
in our words
and in our lives
one of the ways that Christ is proclaimed
is through the Lord's sufferer
the bread and the wine
are symbols of Jesus death
for us to be able to
be able to see Christ
are symbols of Jesus death
for us on the cross
and as we partake
in these elements
we're told in Scripture that we are
through doing that we are proclaiming
the Lord's death until he comes
and as we partake in the Lord's sufferer
by faith we are doing so
in communion
in fellowship
with Christ himself how can that be possible
because Christ has sent
his spirit in the world
you're participating
in the fellowship of the Holy Spirit
as he's making Christ known to us
in the breaking of bread
and in the drinking of this wine
he is present once
so if you have repented of your sin
and you've put your faith in Jesus
God's spirit dwells within you
and you are invited
to participate in this family
meal that we share together
as the people of God in the church
just be clear though
if that's not you
or you're not sure
then maybe refrain from
partaking in this
but instead
ponder think about
what these represent
and I pray that the spirit would lead you
as you ponder the Christ
who is portrayed in these elements
that's what we're going to do now
I'd like for us to pray
and that you spend time just personally
there in prayer with the Lord
and
then Nick is going to then pray and give thanks
for our time of communion together
so let's pause and have a time of personal prayer